I believe you also mentioned in the
Kickstarter campaign that you know for
century Society has viewed silence as
something to be observed during a period
morning yeah have you noticed that
certain cultures are more prone to
silence and certain cultures are embrace
noise more it's a good question I'm
still so early in my research and
development that I don't know if I can
answer that fully I think Asian cultures
definitely seem more prone to silence
and more what's what's the word I'm
looking for
they integrate silence more into their
lifestyles and into their culture and
the religion you know the the Western
world definitely seems to be noisier but
yeah that's unfortunate that's all I can
say it right and right now just cuz I'm
so I'm still trying to figure all this
out and research all this stuff yeah
what do you think your research consists
of a lot of my research will consist of
a lot of reading for sure just in the
last few years there's been over a dozen
books written on this very subject
actually silence and noise mostly noise
yet no documentary film has been made
which is kind of part of the reason why
I'm choosing to do this because it's
like the time is right for something
like this so yeah there's a ton of
reading that I need to do ton of web
research obviously there's a lot of
studies that have been conducted by
organizations like the World Health
Organization and National Institutes of
Health very difficult stuff to get
through but he has a lot of reading that
I need to do as far as that's concerned
as well and then there's like the
research and sort of developing the
aesthetic of the film and kind of the
tone of the film and so that just is
gonna require me immersing myself with
in the work of other artists that I
really appreciate and I kind of want to
mimic like Nathaniel Dorsky who's
celebrated like avant-garde filmmaker
the photography of Ansel Adams and
there's a bunch of photographers I'm
looking at right now so just kind of
immersing myself in that and then you
know going out shooting stuff too
and workshopping ideas do you envision
that all the shots will be local it's
far in the final film you mean order the
work shopping stuff yeah yeah no I
imagine this film to be international
for sure
which means bigger budget unfortunately
but yeah it kind of has to be this is a
global topic it's a global issue and
yeah I don't see any way around having
to travel all over the place I'm looking
at possibly you know eight to ten cities
with throughout the United States
Asia and Europe at this point yeah
and that's that I'm still researching to
division how long the pre-production
process will be and then actual shooting
in the post
yeah yeah the the pre-production phase
because I'm so in it now and kind of
doing a lot of the development working
already we kind of have a good head
start and all that all the
pre-production work but yeah I think I
need about three four months to do
proper pre-production and plan the
production phase properly yeah so your
vision maybe it'll take a couple years
to have it totally finished
unfortunately yeah um yeah I'm picturing
about two years for this film yeah which
is pretty good considering how long
documentaries can sometimes take and
when did you haven't heard even if
you've already said this but when did
you have the first idea about this was
this when you were still doing the
source or read it when did it kind of
start you because you know they'll be
that like idea like mm-hmm
this interesting so you kind of let it
ruminate yeah
when did it happen yeah so yeah I saw
the movie into great silence back in
2006 but I still hadn't come up with an
idea to do a documentary but I was more
just kind of personally interested in
silence and then I read an article about
John Cage and then got really excited
about silence again this is like years
later after watching into great silence
and then I sort of hanged spending some
time with Nathaniel Dorsky this
experimental filmmaker who we actually
hired to consult on the source during
the post-production phase on the side he
does like editing consulting and he's
done that in consulting for POV and
bunch of major documentaries and so I
had the honor and privilege to work with
him and just kind of get to know him and
pick his brain and then I started seeing
his work and turned out he was this
famous like you know experimental
filmmaker and I just love this idea of
like of making a film that's of
something you know rather than about
something and and I think that's when it
all came full circle it was like
integrate silence John Cage and then
Nathaniel Dorsky this is how I can
actually execute this film and it was
kind of a no brainer at that point yeah
so danger question more directly was
probably within the last year so that
that came I came upon it yeah
you